Okay, then. We're in and this is the computing center at cern
[I] mean really this is the brain of the large Hadron collider
Now it's really loud [in] here. It's not a place where I can easily do interviews or give you a live commentary
so I'm recording this afterwards, but I just wanted you [to] see what it looks like and
hear what it sounds like
When you walk [through] these kind of little corridors here
I can't tell [you] how hot it is the hot air is just blasting you from both sides
it's like being in a little oven and
Of course, it's so loud. I mean you can hardly hear yourself think
Now this is really the heart of what cern calls the grid which is a network of computer systems and centers around the world
That's used to process the insane amount of data
produced by the Large Hadron Collider the LhC
Produces about 600 million particle collisions our second and although they don't keep everything. I mean that would be crazy
They just keep a tiny
100,000 snapshots per second
that's still a fair [amount] of viously and that means they're storing about where they're storing over a
Thousand megabytes per second and it makes its [way] here to the data center now the data doesn't just need storing it needs
Processing and that's where the grid comes in
This center is the start of it all and they call it tier zero. It's the tier zero center
Then there are tier one, you get tier twos, and you get tier threes, and they're scattered all over the world
Together they allow thousands of physicists to access all this information and more
Importantly crunch all the data process [it] make sense of it all and I mean just the tier 0
Center here alone does a million jobs a day and it can transfer up to 10 gigabytes of data
Every second and I mean these are just numbers obviously, but when you think about it
They're pretty high numbers
Now as you can [see] here some of these banks some of these racks of computers are kept in kind of these glass enclosures I
Didn't actually ask about that, but I'm assuming it's all sealed so that it's more easy to to keep air-conditioned and to keep cool
Calling this place is just so important and in fact here you see these big blue towers
[I] mean, that's part of the air conditioning system. [I'm] pretty sure they told me if the cooling fails everything gets switched off very quickly
Otherwise they have bit of a meltdown
I do love that you sort of have these little keyboards and computers on the end of the rex [too]
I mean, I mean it's obvious that your wood, but it's somehow amuses me
I'm not sure why I mean I sometimes think the cables behind my computer and television are complicated when I see this place
I feel like my head's going to explode
Now we've come upstairs the [Center's] actually spread over two floors and here
We see the cartridges or tapes that a lot of the information stored on
One of the storage units here for the tapes was actually being worked on while I was there so the door was open and I
Could have a look inside
Now often when the information on these tapes is accessed. There's kind of this robotic, sort of a
device type thing that scurries around the racks and
Pulls out the tapes [and] whenever I wasn't filming it would go whizzing around doing all this cool stuff
But as soon as I started filming it all kind of stopped and I had to wait for ages
But I was determined to show you one in action and eventually eventually I've managed to get this
You get the idea okay now. We've come up to a little sort of room where you can see over the center
This is the [ground-floor] part of the center again
You can see how high the ceiling is that's actually not a good thing modern data centers actually have low ceilings
I think it's because it's easier to cool the rooms if the rooms are smaller
But this was built at a time when well computers were a lot bigger
it's actually in a lot of ways the building in the rooms quite outdated for the purpose, but
They're still using it [I]
think it's certain they prefer spending their money on a new kit rather than new buildings and
They're still doing a pretty good job and here's one last thing. I want to show you it's actually outside the computer center
They call this the soon animal shelter for computer mice
It's bit of a joke
But it's where the it's where the computer mice go to retire when they're then no longer in use
Is mice the plural [where] [the] mouse's must be mice?
Anyway there it is. It's a bit of fun now
[as] I said it was remarkably loud in the center, so it wasn't really easy to do interviews
But I did do interviews [with] people that work here at the computer Centre
You're going to be [able] to see them [very] soon here [on] computer file
Sean who I work with is going to be having all that going through all adding it together soon
So stay tuned for that also while we were at cern
We made a music video for the sixty symbols channel if you haven't seen that yet
Go and have a look it was a bit of fun
And I also recorded something about the corridor where the world wide web was developed and that video is already on computer file
So you can go and check that out, too?
There's so much to look at thanks for watching this and we hope to see you soon for more videos